I'd like it to be relaxing calming and
amusing I would like people to be a
little bit amazed to figure out how they
work to solve the problem of how it
works my name is David Roy I'm a kinetic
sculptor I've been doing it for in
excess of 40 years Roy's kinetic
sculptures are mesmerizing feat of
artistry and engineering a single wine
can provide hours of entertainment
some of them create tension that some of
them are just something you can sit like
you would watch a fire and just get lost
in the flames and he's made a lot of
them over the years the different
designs there's over 300 in the number
of pieces because I make additions is
seven thousand something like that each
one of Roy's pieces is entirely
mechanically driven no motors no
electronics and his degree in physics
comes in handy when explaining how they
work you start with an energy source I
use a constant force spring now I
initially started with a weight Drive
each is controlled by what's called an
escapement mechanism a device that
releases energy incrementally it's
similar to what you might find inside a
clock so the mechanism initially is
locked so that the weight can't fall a
spring can't unwind when that mechanism
is unlocked it releases a bit of energy
which in turn moves a second device
often a rotating wheel that device
creates motion but it also retractors
the escapement releasing a bit more
energy and restarting the cycle and
that's the essence of an escapement
controlled release of energy that's
self-sustaining until it runs out of
energy and you have to wind it up and
nothing is perpetual lastly there is a
large group of people who say is it
perpetual motion and of course I was
schooled in physics and they know that
that isn't possible so they're not one
of the key laws of physics is the
conservation of energy which basically
says the amount of energy you put into a
system is exactly the amount you get out
one way or another
the user puts energy in by winding them
up and then the energy comes out in the
motion which is the part I want but
another way is in the sounds that takes
energy to create the sound but most of
it a lot of it gets lost in heat due to
friction where the things are rotating
and rubbing Roy is tinkered with
different mechanisms and materials to
try to curtail some of that energy loss
so that's where it appears perpetual
only because I worked really hard to
reduce friction and sound
Roy's always had a strong grasp of the
science and the mechanics behind his
work but he needed a little help with
the artistry I mean he can make a neat
thing but you have to make it work
visually and that was probably the
hardest for me to learn over the years
and that was my my mentor and tutor of
my wife in fact it was David's wife
Margie who sparked his initial interest
in kinetic sculpture Margie was a
sculpture major at the Rhode Island
School of Design and she made project
that is two cogs and wouldn't chain and
she put it on the wall and she said this
is my sculpture and I said you can make
a machine and call it a sculpture and
she looked at me she said of course nice
okay so that was that idea that you
could make wooden machines in column
sculpture that totally reach annals my
creative ideas from the science world
the engineering world to the art world
and it was all brand-new and very
exciting and what started as a hobby
quickly became a full-fledged business
most people and I have to admit I didn't
think it was a long-term thing it was
something we were doing because we could
we had no obligations and I was playing
I was having a great time
decades later Roy is still making and
selling kinetic sculptures and its
continued passion is due to one thing I
like to solve problems that I dream up I
created the first sculptures and then
they were noisy and annoying and I
wanted to make him quiet so then I had
to develop a mechanism that was quiet
and he did in a piece called
anticipation but the problem-solving
didn't stop there
getting longer run times
has been a one of the challenges that I
enjoy the first pieces they ran for 20
minutes 25 minutes when I got that up to
an hour I thought I was in nirvana and
then it got to three hours this is over
years this didn't happen quickly
the current piece the longest one I've
run is probably runs for 48 hours 50
hours there's a cost to these long
runtimes what gets you there really long
runtimes is really slow motion which you
know it can be nice but it just isn't as
entertaining in fact of another
challenge Roy is thought for himself
over the years to get his sculptures to
produce all kinds of different motion
the initial ones were simple motion just
creating the motion as I gained control
I developed ones that create patterns
and optical patterns and those basically
two circular wheels going opposite
directions or the same direction
depending on the pattern the next
category that came were more the
floating motion I call that the bird
motion and that's where you'll get a
motion up and down back and forth but
straight-line motion or spiral motion
mixed amongst those I've tried to do
other ones that create randomness so
that your optical pattern doesn't stay
the same it changes these days Roy is
focused on creating chaotic motion in
his pieces chaotic motion is motion that
changes at unpredictable intervals so it
can go fast it can go slow but you can't
tell when that's gonna happen and so
chaotic motion that's a term it's well
defined it's used in physics it's used
in engineering but to try to use it in
art and to create a chaotic motion is
extremely challenging Roy was able to
deliberately create chaotic motion for
the first time a few years ago and a
piece aptly named chaos and I'm working
in other ones now trying to use what I
learned from that and to push the
envelope of well what can I do next
building one of these sculptures can be
a slow and complicated process the
initial designs float around in my head
so there's a lot of daydreaming a lot
thinking next ROI sketches out his
design on computer I draw an illustrator
and I animate usually in Adobe After
Effects animating the piece before
building it helps Roy understand what
the sculptures patterns will look like
it's also another program it's called
working model I use it to calculate the
center of mass of complicated
arrangements of parts that calculation
is critical to getting the balance right
so that the sculpture moves in the
intended way the trouble with the
program is it doesn't exist anymore at
least it doesn't for Mac there haven't
been a current version for years but Roy
is a workaround I buy really old eye
books which are the last computers that
would run it so that is actually a key
program but it's one I live in fear that
all my old computers are gonna die one
day and it won't work anymore and then
probably retired at that point
Roy tinker's in these computer programs
until he's satisfied with the overall
design then he sends a file over to a
local woodworker who cuts out some of
the individual parts on a CNC machine
the rest of it all has to be done by
hand the basic tools are drill press
Sanders and bandsaw and then there's all
kinds of hand tools
hammers and hand drills and all of that
Roy uses these tools to build small
parts like pulleys and levers as well as
to smooth out and finish off the larger
machine cut pieces once all the pieces
are finished and stained Roy then
assembles and tests the sculptures all
of the large wooden parts have to be
balanced because wood is not uniform I
have developed techniques there used
tiny little brass weights that are
embedded in the back to get things to
balance the assembly probably is where I
spend most time and then also very
important is testing so I have large
walls I put up the sculptures and I
leave them running for days and I want
to get all the bugs out before a
customer gets it so testing is also a
big part of the assembly and making
process one of Roy's new sculptures is
in this phase of production he's been
using tape and small press waits to
tinker with the bounce eventually I get
an intuitive feel but the only way to
get that
by spending hours adding weight then
standing and staring at it my wife
laughs I just stand around and stare at
sculptures all day but that's how I
learn and get a feel for what they need
after a sculpture is assembled perfectly
balanced in quality control there's
still one final step so a big part of
the design and the work is naming and we
have a list that we have kept of all
different names that we've thought of
over the years must have two or three
hundred names now we've used two or
three hundred names already when a new
son-in-law joined the family he was
fresh to the game and he was good he got
several right off the bat but its naming
is difficult from designing to tinkering
to naming the entire process can take a
while I have had pieces that started and
took over a year more some I put aside
because they couldn't get what I liked
and then went back to him after a while
and then some I have an idea and it
comes out and it comes out right and
those are kind of boring because they
just worked and while it's frustrating
when things don't work Roy recognizes
that it's all part of the process the
frustration is kind of nice to have
because it makes the joy after better
but one follows the other that I don't
think I've ever done a piece where I
haven't been disappointed in it
initially and then had to work through
that and try to figure it out and Roy's
passion for finding creative solutions
isn't flowing down anytime soon I had a
brother-in-law who when we started this
he said this is great but you're gonna
run out of ideas and then what are you
gonna do and that was 40 years ago it
has just been one thing after another I
thought I would run out but I'm you know
pushing 70 years old and there's still
lots of that I want to do so it's
because of the problems I like to solve
the problems
[Music]